so let me start by thanking the
organizers for inviting me great excuse
to spend a week in Berkeley and quite
happy to talk about some fairly recent
work today on parallel active learning
this is joint work with Leon Batu
Miroslav dudek and John Lankford at
Microsoft Research so let me start by
giving some motivation for the direction
we're exploring them in this world this
is going to be I talk about distributed
machine learning so in order to motivate
it I'm going to very briefly say a few
words about many existing distributed
machine learning approaches i'm going to
do so without naming any names because
how the people in this room have either
worked on some algorithms of this nature
or are good friends with somebody who
has so you know this work already so
there's quite a few distributed machine
learning approaches that are out there
at this point a lot of them often work
by paralyzing existing algorithms so a
lot of works around distributed
optimization would say fall into this
category often the existing algorithms
don't parallel is sort of as is but you
have to change some things around so an
example could be something like
distributed mini batches and under a
variety of other approaches such as
bagging or model averaging which try to
somewhat recognize the fact that maybe
this is not an arbitrary computational
problem but we're trying to actually at
heart address a statistical problem when
we are doing this tweeted machine
learning and maybe there's something we
can you know do simple on individual
machines and then aggregate information
somehow and so on and so there's a good
number of such approaches and let me
start by maybe outlining a couple of
implicit assumptions or limitations that
are often present in these approaches
and then we can think about how we might
improve the state of the art by relaxing
these further so one kind of I would
implicit or explicit assumption in a lot
of the existing approaches is that the
model that we are trying to learn is
relatively personal parsimonious so it's
simple to communicate in a cheap fashion
or if not the model directly maybe the
gradients in an optimization framework
can be communicated in a cheap way there
are things like if you're doing
something like model averaging then or
then things like averaging have to make
sense to begin with and have to be sound
and we're going to see more about in in
the next slide when these sorts of
simple assumptions can fail another
thing that some sometimes a little
bothersome is that the statistical
structure of the problem really you know
when we are doing distributed machine
learning it's not like there is just an
arbitrary computational problem that we
are solving there is there is data and
there is some structure to it and often
the we ignore this structure while
designing it's treated machine learning
algorithms you're not very careful about
it maybe we use the fact that the data
is iid across different machines
sometimes but not much more than that
and maybe you can do better if you think
more carefully about the properties of
this data that we're dealing with so let
me start with the first limitation that
I mentioned which is the models might
not always be parsimoniously described
so perhaps the the easiest to see
example here is if you're working with
something that somewhat nonparametric as
your learning algorithm so for instance
if you're doing a kernel methods such as
a kernel support vector machine then in
order to describe your model you need
not just you know a simple vector of
weights or something but you also need
to have your data points your training
data or some subset of your training
data with you in order to meaningfully
describe the model now if you want to
communicate the model that means you're
also going to be communicating a lot of
data and this this is of course not just
limited to Colonel svms but if you're
doing things like nearest neighbors or
any other kernel methods or even a high
dimensional linear model you have to
think twice before you talk about
communication of a model or the gradient
of a model so that is one thing to keep
in mind
the second thing to keep in mind is
things like model averaging can fail in
simple ways so consider a very common
example of matrix factorization that
arises in contexts of recommendation
systems sparse coding or variety of
other applications now for a matrix m UV
is a good factorization minus u minus V
is a good factorization you average the
two you get zero so you have to be
careful when you model average and this
is not a one-off it is fairly generic
when your model representation is non
convex in the parameters no matter how
hard we try to avoid this these problems
to come up every now and then things
like neural networks mixture models and
many representations have these issues
so it's something worth thinking about
and saying can we have a method that's
robust to failure modes such as these
mentioned here now second part of course
when we talk about having large
quantities of data we have a lot of data
but do we really need all the data so
certainly talk very nicely about these
issues in the morning in context of
corsets and this this problem kind of
fairly generally arises also in
distributed machine learning so for
instance here you know we were just is a
very cartoon example we are trying to
distinguish between the red circles in
the blue squares and we are just trying
to do it we are linear classifier and of
course given the state HPD obvious that
this black line is a good classifier but
of course if I gave you just the six
green points instead of all the
remaining data you would probably still
come up with the same black line and if
somebody gave these six points to us in
advance then our computational problem
would be fantastically simple right and
this is essentially the intuition that's
used in support vector machines where we
or where we maybe try to find these six
green points and in fact exploiting this
has been looked at in works for in
existing words for paralyzing Colonel
SVM's as well as more generically in the
context of
computational complexity by nina and
co-authors and by hal dom and co-authors
and we're going to see a bit of this in
Nina's talk tomorrow i believe so there
is there is a generic way by the way of
describing this this situation that we
we saw before this you know intuition of
a few number of informative data points
this can be captured fairly broadly
there is a whole field around it called
active learning which essentially tries
to solve this precise problem go over a
large collection of data try to find the
examples that are most informative
towards the statistical problem at hand
and then use them for learning and this
is a similar idea support vectors but
word small lot more broadly and the nice
thing is at this point we have efficient
algorithms or in many cases more even
more efficient heuristics to solve this
these this sort of a question for many
generic hypothesis classes loss
functions and so on right so a simple
example of this would be maybe so if you
are doing binary classification and we
receive a data point X we have a current
classifier H of X and we are trying to
predict plus 1 or minus 1 based on the
sign of H of X then a pretty generic
form of rule here often is that you look
at the absolute value of H of X if its
large and we are very confident in our
prediction you know we are going to
sample this point X with a small
probability if it's close to zero then
we can sample this point with a large
probabilities or you could for instance
look at a data point X look at its
similarities with the points you've
queried in the past and design a
querying rule based on the similarity
these examples of both are known in the
literature so so this is one primitive
that kind of tries to maybe explore
exploit the statistical structure of the
problem somewhat more carefully and
maybe we can use this to inform our
distributed machine learning algorithms
somehow okay so here is a very simple
idea of how one might go about doing
that
so we have a we are a cluster of
computers each gray box here denotes a
denotes a computer in a cluster the
computer has some local data set on
local storage which it has access to now
what it tries to do in parallel each
computer goes over the local data and
tries to find out the informative
examples using some for instance active
learning algorithm it takes the
informative ones and communicates them
to all the other nodes in the cluster
and then each node takes the collection
of all the informative examples that are
found by anybody here and updates the
model locally and the intuition is that
the total number of informative examples
that you might find is fairly small
across everything so once you found them
then doing the model update locally is
probably not too expensive okay so this
is fairly simple intuition you can turn
it into an algorithm fairly easily so
let's see a synchronous instantiation of
an algorithm that does this so what we
have is we start from some initial
hypothesis h1 we have some fixed bat
size B we have to either them
algorithmic primitives we are going to
assume for now so there is an active
learning algorithm which we call a
sifter a and that is a passive updater p
I'm going to again give concrete
examples of these in a couple of minutes
on the slide so basically the algorithm
proceeds and rounds at each round you
take you look at be examples in parallel
so each node each of the K nodes look at
looks at be over K examples locally and
uses the active sifter locally to create
a subsample data set of a certain size
and then these selected examples are
broadcast over the network and now each
node locally can update go from HT to
http 1 by running the passive updater p
on the sub sampled data on the selected
data right so a bit more concretely for
instance you could be doing this say for
Colonel SVM's
HT would be your current colonel svn
solution at time T based on whatever
subsample data you've seen so far maybe
you use this a query rule based on the
absolute value of HT of X to create the
subsample data on each node share this
over the network and then you go from HT
to http us one by using an online
Colonel SVM update rule on the subsample
data and there are few examples of how
to do this again that I will be happy to
describe you you can make this
asynchronous fairly easily so the idea
is almost the same except you do not
really sorry I shouldn't really have a
bad size be here anymore that is for the
synchronous so now you do something very
simple you take each node and you
basically attached 2 q's to each node 1
q is going to be a queue of selected
examples that have been identified as
informative by some node in the network
and another queue is going to be
examples that are waiting to be
processed by the active sifter so while
you have selected examples available to
you you keep on updating your hypothesis
by using these examples at some point
maybe you run out of them at that point
you turn to your local data and start
sifting through your local data till you
find some informative examples again and
whenever you find one you broadcast you
add it to the queue of every node in the
network you just do a broadcast it is a
fairly simple again we can a reason a
little bit about the computational
complexity of a procedure like this I am
going to define some simple primitives
to help us reason about it so we're
going to assume that the computational
complexity of our passive updater p is T
of n so in it takes an examples and it
time t of m spits out a model so then
this is this is the running time but
that we are going to have for the
sequential passive algorithm running on
one machine now in order to look at the
communication complexity of
computational complexity of active
learning we need
a little bit more narration but it's a
fairly simple will parse it together so
we define a quantity s of n which is
roughly think about it as the complexity
of a model trained on n examples so if
you take a model that has been trained
on n examples and use it to predict on a
fresh example X then it is going to take
you time s of n okay so if for predict
for after training on ten examples you
have completed it takes us of ten time
to predict on a new example we also
assume that the active shifter if it
gets n examples it is going to subsample
a set of size fee of n okay then the
roughly the pipeline that we might have
for a sequential active approach that
similar to our parallel approach would
be you you put n examples through here
you get fee of n out here these fearful
are processed by the passive updater and
in time T of PN it spits out a model and
now how much time do we spend in the
active active learning algorithm well
this depends on the active learning
algorithm being used but a fairly
generous estimate is to say that the
complexity of active learning is may be
the same as the complexity of computing
a prediction and in order to do that you
evaluate the model which will have a
complexity now s of fee n because your
computing the model with you just fee of
n examples remember there is a constant
baton forth between these so your model
never has a complexity more than SF en
and your computing it on about n
examples because each example goes into
the active sifter so this is going to be
n times s of fee n is the complexity
roughly of the active learning part and
then t of pn is the complexity of the
passive updater so that is the net time
complexity of sequential active and now
what happens when we deployed as in
parallel is basically we are going to
look at the end examples not
sequentially but in parallel so each
node is just going to eat shifter is
only going to go over n over K examples
and hence the first part of the complex
t goes from n n times s 2 n times s over
K so so this is the part where you gain
from going sequential to parallel and
the second part remains the same now if
you want to think about where what might
be the ordering between these things
looking like we can instantiate these
with specific examples so for instance
we can take the example of a kernel svm
so if you use a good algorithm you might
hope to have a TN of about Oh n square s
of n usually grows linearly with n the
number of support vectors in here
usually grows linearly with the number
of data points for a good day for these
techniques is when you find fee of fun
to be much much smaller than n that's
where active learning is doing something
non trivial and plugging this in the
expression for sfn we see that ta t of n
is already much much larger than n times
s of fee n because TN is n times n s of
fee n is n times p n which is much
smaller than T of N and then we get a
further speed up dividing this by K when
we go from sequential to parallel so
what we see in the kernel sqm example is
that when we go from passive to active
we already get a computational speed up
and then we get another computational
speed up when we go to parallel we can
look at a different setting so if you do
example of a non-convex model I was
talking about before like neural net
with back propagation so here TN is just
linear in the number of examples usually
and SN does not depend on the number of
examples because the model has a fixed
complexity it just depends on the number
of parameters you're learning we still
hope that fee of n is much much smaller
than n but in this case what we see is
that in sequential setting we do not get
any gain from going from passive to
active because this is order n this is
order n what we still hope to get is
a reduction here when we go from
sequential to parallel which will cut
down one term here and this term is
still order fee n so it is hopefully
much more smaller than this term which
is order n right so at least roughly we
hope that still going from sequential to
sequential does not give us something
but sequential to parallel still gives
us something non trivial so the rounds
of communication really depend on I
guess the batch size that you are using
relative to the number of examples so
this in some sense is the hyper
parameter that you can play with right
but I handle all the communication
complexity of the algorithm which you're
really alluding to depends on the query
complexity of the underlying active
learning approach and I'm going to leave
it to you tomorrow to say most of the
things about it there is only one remark
I want to make here so one thing we have
to be careful about is that so typically
we assume in active learning that when
we do query complexity kind of analysis
that we see an example we decide whether
we are going to query the label or not
and if we decide we see that label and
update our model basically immediately
but whereas now we don't so again if we
go to the concrete slide here we go or a
batch of size B collect all the examples
that seem informative update the model
after we've collected these examples so
there is a delay of about be here
between deciding whether an example is
informative and then updating the model
and this this might actually be
dangerous because this might mean that
the query complexity of active learning
goes up by a lot when we do this and
this is bad for communication complexity
so thankfully this is not the case so we
have we have some analysis for a special
for at least an example of active
learning rule and I know it's true for
at least a couple of others where
this delay is not too harmful what you
can show is that if fee of n was a sub
sampling rate without delays then wait
delays it's just about t + C of n minus
tau plus P of n minus tau so it's it is
not to catastrophic at all in fact I
would say that the behavior of the
asynchronous version with delays here is
much nicer almost than what we would
expect to have say with the usual
distributed optimization kind of
algorithms you are more familiar with
okay so in the remaining time I wanna
say a little bit about experimental
evaluation that we did for this
algorithm so I'm going to describe one
simulation in one experiment both of
them were done with a handwritten digit
of ignition dataset mms but was not the
standard data said it was an enlarged
version of the dataset created by Elyon
go to which takes the original digits
and does some elastic deformations of
this of them and results in about 8.1
million examples we did a simulation for
Colonel SVM and this was with an RBF
kernel used an online Colonel SVM
algorithm we did a parallel
implementation of single hidden layer
neural Nets the active learning rule was
fairly simple selecting point X with
probability based on the absolute value
of the current classifier in such a way
that the sub sampling rate is something
we like to have for communication so for
the first for the stimulation here is
how we did it we basically simulate it's
increments per active learning so you
fix a bad size be split into portions of
size B of B over K sift each portion in
turn take the largest splitting sifting
time then we update the model with new
exam with these with the selected
examples take the training time to
update the model and use the sum of
these two as an implement as an
approximation of the parallel
computation time so what we are ignoring
here is the communication time but I
don't think it's actually in the
experiments have done so far the
communication time seems fairly fairly
controllable so I don't think there's a
particular issue so
what we see is for the colonel SVM's the
improvements were actually quite quite
nice quite striking i am going to
completely skip this plot and look look
at the more interpretable part plot
which is which is speed ups so so the
task here we were looking at was
classifying the pair of digits 1 13 vs
57 this is fairly fairly calm this is
one of the more difficult sub problems
within am nest and we were measuring the
speed up over running the sequential
passive algorithm with respect to the
number of nodes for different different
amount of tester and these these are
test tester numbers over I think about
4000 test examples so what we see is
that we do get speed ups and the speed
ups are more pronounced when we look at
smaller error rates because that means
we are essentially looking into later
and later iterations of the algorithm so
the algorithm basically gets to run for
longer and the hence the speed-up
usually gets more pronounced when you do
that and it is it is reasonably so the
dotted black line here would be a linear
speed-up and what we see is the speed up
does seem fairly close to linear often
and eventually it starts paper out
around 100 nodes or so yes yes yes yes
bats eyes stays the same and we change k
was so here i just used about thousand
per class or actually it was sixty
thousand so it was six it was about six
thousand per class sorry now thousand
thousand per class my sorry so so yeah i
just used thousand per class i didn't i
didn't play much with that
right right so so yeah so if I if I when
I when I actually run this on the
cluster I would probably use so a rule
of thumb i use when i try to run this on
the cluster is you essentially for
whatever bad size you're using maybe one
good so the simplest thing to try is if
you have K nodes just use a bad size of
K squared so each node finds one out of
K that looks relevant and then you find
k out of K squared and this seems to
work reasonably well without so far
being being too computationally
expensive but but again this is
something that you can easily play with
once you have the implementation ok the
the other the other kind of obvious
benchmark to look at here is ok sure we
get some improvement over passive but in
kernel SMS we saw that actually active
is already doing better than passive so
maybe the gain is entirely due to using
active learning and not due to using
parallel learning thankfully that's not
the case and when we plot the speed up
our sequential active the speed ups are
lesser but still there and still near
linear up until about 100 nodes the
story with new rights is less exciting
with the extent of speed ups here is
less I think that's partly because of
the linear complexity of running time
complexity everything just ends very
quickly and there is not enough room to
room to do speed ups but what we do see
is initially the error definitely drops
much faster for using parallel active
learning but eventually they all start
to look about the same and there isn't
that much we are able to gain by it so
so here I think it seems really
worthwhile to actually experiment with
larger data sets where new Knights have
larger running times and we are playing
around with some data sets of that form
now but knee
is showing me that I am more or less out
of times I should wrap up here I think
at a higher level this seems like a
fairly nice general strategy for
distributed machine learning primarily
because it seems to be applicable to
slightly more diversity of hypothesis
classes and algorithms then maybe some
of the existing approaches it's
particularly appealing for nonparametric
and or non convex models that have maybe
not received as much attention before
and all in all it seems theoretically
reasonably well motivated and
empirically fairly promising so in terms
of going forward we would like to also
do a real distributed implementation for
Colonel SVM's at least and maybe for
some other algorithms evaluate things on
more data sets and maybe use different
sub sampling strategies and so on but in
the interest of time I'm going to stop
here and happy to take any questions